wow
that was too hot don't eat directly off
the griddle people that's really stupid
oh oh
oh hot nuts you oh okay ow hot nuts ah
what's up yo
[Music]
i just burned my esophagus
mother
oh i'm [ __ ] hot hi
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
just took me to do that
oh yeah oh baby wow way
so now you have oh [ __ ]
very hot fun
oh [ __ ] is hot oh it's still pink in the
middle oh [ __ ] it's hot and on top of
that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's hot oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] whoa
oh ow
top oh [ __ ]
which could be hot be careful how did
they not burn themselves ah that's hot
that's yeah okay
beef ow burger
oh [ __ ] oh no burning oh god all right
okay
there you go ah that's really hot
actually they doped the bun to get it
ready
okay
oh yeah
hot stuff
okay that's good very good put it into
the steamer
that yay
steam is hot people oh [ __ ]
ow it's just my belly not a big deal oh
my god
oh [ __ ] draining oh yeah right
that's hot no don't touch that [ __ ]
idiot
no that's good
oh
[Music]
[Music]
never [ __ ] learned man
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
very hot fun oh [ __ ] bro oh [ __ ]
hi i'm george moats burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here
perfect
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] oh yeah
okay
you see this